j'ai produit child d'abord vous êtes un
des groupes que je préfère ensuite dit
merci merci ensuite j'aimerais que vous
vous définissiez un petit peu parce que
je crois qu'on ne vous a jamais entendu
parler à la télévision et je vais vous
parler un peu de votre métier le métier
qu'on fait ce métier que le monde
connaisse physique
l'artiste c'est un beau métier on aime
beaucoup ça c'est pas mal les grecs puis
à 10 ans français combien ça fait un an
exactement en même temps chatila bah oui
le nôtre car elle comprend parce que là
bas je n'ai pas beaucoup en fin de temps
en temps et quand vous avez commencé ça
a marché tout de suite ici en france oui
on a eu leur chance je mets les choses
grand succès le début il nous à nous
donner nous a poussé on peut dire ça
vous avez de la chance vous avez aussi
des voix est des instruments ça c'est
quand vous vous dites ça ou encore à
votre avis vous voyez moi toute façon je
vois souvent la télé je vois qu est-ce
que c'est n'importe quoi vous dites
c'est quelque chose des raids
je peux pas m'arrêter en français je
comprends donc quand ils veulent part de
ça
je parlais des instruments aussi parce
que je crois que vous essayez de plus en
plus d'introduire des instruments de
notre pays dans le music de rock oui
c'est quelque chose qu'on aime beaucoup
nous faire ça paraît loin de cet
instrument
ça ça va très très bien selon sa date de
1790 vous savez le bouzouki et
spécialement ça ça c'est le vrai bijou
qui parce qu'il est à les autres
bouzouki qui existent aujourd'hui grèce
du coup tu roules à ça c'est le vrai je
crois pas qu'il ya beaucoup de ce fait
se fait avec du charbon
ouais charbon de bois charbon du charbon
dans puis tout seul
après on commence et s'arrête en gratuit
l'arrondissement oui c'est l'instrument
qu'est printemps parce qu'il y avait les
turcs pendant quatre siècles dans les
quatre siècles et conduit les légendes
monde ip lait
les fans très qui s'étaient enfermés
dans leur maison pendant les quatre
siècles des turcs et il est chanté la
liberté de la presse avec les gens se
passe c'est vrai mais ça ce que je sais
c'est que ça c'est le véritable bouzouki
on aime beaucoup le son de ce truc là
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses on
essaie de jouer des musiques modernes où
il ya beaucoup de choses intéressantes
de son poème donné raison
il se sent bien
cependant son d'une guitare ce même une
guitare avec de scort la production
où
il ya quelque chose d'autre il est sur
le bois c'est beaucoup de choses
en plus d'études n'est pas comme s'il
avait un trou il y avait un autre sous
nécessaire qu'il y ait ça il ya le canon
106 ceci n'existe pas 1 le dernier on
avait la chance de lâcheté oui mais
voilà dernier safina ça par exemple
c'est du bois de peau de poisson
voilà ça c'est des décors de
de nylon sur et ça ce sont des petits
trucs qui permettent peut avoir les par
les deux mi temps mais l'écart et dans
le quart du temps parce qu'il a le dit
mi temps mais ça c'est le seul perdu
tant qu'équipe
parce que vous voyez dans la musique
orientale il y a on partage on partage
les tons alors c'est à ces lieux se sont
bien un ami c'est une antique par hasard
on a trouvé sa grève oui je ne joue pas
on peut trouver mais pas ça on est
toujours dans une fête folklorique
coupable dans une petit village grec
s'est on a vu ça je crois que si je me
souviens bien notre premier succès a été
à partir de la musique classique
oui c'était le cas l'an dash-l belgique
ne s'est pas les cas ils parlent de long
a coûté ce sont des harmonies classique
nice et ensuite de 400 monique l'a4
monique presse classique oui on a coûté
ça et puis un film elodie sur les
harmonies ça sur cette mer mariage du
succès parce que la musique classique
c'est quelque chose de prendre le moyen
du monde il aime ça beaucoup de monde il
aime la musique classique ne faut
surtout pas qu'on essaye de trouver des
choses simples que le plus difficile
c'est de trouver des choses simples y
avait toujours ses cinq ans et me voilà
[Musique]